tras dos días de crisis varias reuniones
virtuales entre la reina isabel y los
herederos al trono los príncipes carlos
y william finalmente la familia real ha
respondido esta noche a la explosiva
entrevista de los duques de sas ex en
una declaración de nueve líneas del
palacio de buckingham en nombre de la
reina isabel se asegura que la familia
real se siente triste al conocer las
dificultades vividas por megan y harvey
y que tratará privadamente las denuncias
que hicieron de esta manera la familia
real intenta acabar con la polémica
diciendo que es un asunto familiar pero
lejos de que esto suceda lo que quiere
la gente ahora es que se quite ese manto
de duda de racismo sobre la institución
especialmente por los efectos que a
futuro puede tener esto para la
monarquía británica ahora lo que se
quiere saber es quién porque hay dudas
sobre todos los integrantes de la
familia salvo la reina y su esposo el
duque de edimburgo hizo sus comentarios
ocupación sobre el color de piel del
niño archi y también lo que se quiere
saber es quién evitó no permitió que
megan marco le tuviera ayuda profesional
cuando expreso tener pensamientos
suicidas entretanto y para mostrarles
cómo está la situación a nivel interno
hoy se ha conocido una encuesta de la
firma yougov que tiene empate el 32 por
ciento apoya a la reina otro 32% apoya a
los duques y otro 36% no sabe a quién
apoyar los jóvenes están a favor de los
duques mientras que los mayores a favor
de la reina isabel segunda